le cessez-le-feu dans une guerre vieille
de huit ans bagdad et téhéran sont enfin
d'accord le secrétaire général de l'onu
son principal artisan l'annoncera lundi
où marx démission du président de la
sncf a accepté par le ministre des
transports polémique sur la sécurité sur
les conditions de travail et amertume
chez les cheminots
ce sont les trois conséquences de
l'accident de la gare de l'est
le savoir vivre est un art qu'il faut
maîtriser pour refaire le monde le grand
monde tout ça prend du baisemain au port
de la fourchette mais tout se paie en
tout cas c'est à la mode
madame monsieur bonsoir ce ballet
diplomatique la dure depuis le 18
juillet dernier date à laquelle téhéran
a annoncé son intention d'accéder aux
recommandations de paix de l'onu l'irak
jusqu'à hier est resté réservé quant à
un accord de cessez le feu
les verrous des conditions préalables
ont enfin sauter aujourd'hui après trois
semaines d'intenses efforts
diplomatiques du secrétaire général de
l'onu monsieur perez de cuellar
tout est donc en place pour stopper une
sinistre comptabilité en huit ans cette
guerre du golfe aura fait plus d'un
million de morts autant de blessés et
aura coûté 400 milliards de dollars
jacques merlino le secrétaire général de
l'onu peut être aujourd'hui satisfait il
a réussi sa médiation entre l'irak et
l'iran en guerre depuis huit ans hier il
recevait des mains du représentant
irakien nations unies une déclaration du
président saddam hussein selon laquelle
l'irak était prêt à accepter un
cessez-le-feu à la condition que l'iran
s'engage sans équivoque officiellement à
ouvrir immédiatement après ce
cessez-le-feu des négociations directes
la réponse de téhéran est tombée cet
après midi la délégation iranienne à
l'onu déclarait qu'elle était prête à
mener les négociations directes avec
l'irak
dès le cessez le feu cela dans le cadre
de la résolution 598 et sous les
auspices secrétaire général ce n'est pas
la première fois qu'un cessez-le-feu et
décider entre les deux pays
mais aujourd'hui il semble bien que l'on
soit sur la bonne voie isolement
diplomatique de l'iran ce dernier revers
militaires la fatigue d'une population
lassée par les 10
lyon de ce dirigeant sont autant de
facteurs qui poussent l'iran a accepté
de mettre un terme à cette guerre qui
aura fait plus d'un million de morts en
huit ans il reste pour secrétaire
général de l'onu a décidé du jour
d'entrée en vigueur du cessez-le-feu
il pourrait annoncer cette date en tout
début de la semaine prochaine
c'est dans un prochain conseil des
ministres que sera nommé le successeur
de philippe rouvillois le président de
la sncf dont la démission a été acceptée
ce matin par le ministre des transports
c'est l'une des conséquences de
l'accident de la gare de l'est qui a
fait un mort et 57 blessés sept d'entre
eux reste hospitalisé ce soir mais sont
hors de danger pour les syndicats
changer un homme ne règle pas le
problème étant la cgt que la cfdt trouve
dans cet accident survenu un mois à
peine après celui de la gare de lyon de
nouveaux arguments pour relancer la
polémique sur les conditions de sécurité
et les conditions de travail
alain douguet ski pour la cgt ce qui est
en cause c'est le concept de rentabilité
de la sncf par exemple la suppression de
dix mille emplois par an pendant quatre
ans cette politique visait syndicats et
source d'incidents nombreux ils peuvent
devenir dramatique
et ces incidents en ligne sont de plus
en plus fréquents ils ont ils ont des
causes diverses ce soit des problèmes
dead d'entretien du matériel soit des
problèmes de signalisation soit des
problèmes d'entretien de la voie et
c'est tout cet ensemble qui fragilise
siglé vous mettez en cause des cadences
de travail il y a également des
problèmes de conditions de travail et
notamment des conditions de travail pour
la les personnels de la région
parisienne
si vous voulez en région parisienne il y
a le phénomène suivant c'est qu'il y a
de plus en plus de voyageurs et et qui
voyagent de plus en plus loin ça vient
d'une certaine délocalisation si vous
voulez de l'emploi par rapport villes
nouvelles qui sont créés et cela crée un
influent de voyageurs supplémentaires
le problème aujourd'hui c'est de dire
trouvons les moyens pour remédier à
cette situation et feu refaisons de la
sncf l'entreprise où l'on voyage avec le
plus de sécurité
la cgt estime qu'avec la démission du
pdg le gouvernement tente de camoufler
ses propres responsabilités
pour la cfdt changer un homme ne réglera
pas les problèmes il faut s'attaquer à
leur cause
bien reçu dit le ministre des transports
michel delebarre il va faire participer
les syndicats de cheminots aux analyses
et à l'élaboration des mesures à prendre
une commission d' enquête va être créée
en association avec les représentants du
personnel de la sncf la cgt la cfdt qui
appelle d'ailleurs demain à 17 heures un
rassemblement des cheminots gare de
l'est
les causes de l'accident maintenant
l'état actuel de l'enquêté elles peuvent
se résumer à cette question comment
freiner un train de 220 tonnes alors que
les moteurs pousse toujours le convoi
c'est la difficulté à laquelle a été
confronté le conducteur du train patrick
esther hier soir les enquêteurs de la
justice et de l'identité judiciaire ont
tenté de recueillir le maximum
d'informations sur la rame accidentée
la lecture du disque du mouchard a déjà
permis de déterminer que le conducteur a
effectivement déclencher les freins le
manomètre de pression en chutant prouve
que ceux ci on fonce
sonné si la ram a malgré tout percuté le
butoir
il faut chercher l'explication ailleurs
en effet ce même mouchard signale que
les moteurs de la machine n'était pas à
l'arrêt le conducteur se trouvait à
l'avant du train dans une cabine de
télécommande installé dans la première
voiture
la motrice elle était placée à l'arrière
de la rame qui était donc pousser
lorsque le conducteur a freiné
il semble que la motrice et continuer à
pousser le train le projetant dans le
butoir à une vingtaine de kilomètres
heure on peut donc envisager une panne
de circuit entre l'avant et l'arrière de
la rame mais aussi que le conducteur
n'ait pas couper totalement
l'alimentation électrique des moteurs
qu'il faut comprendre ce qui s'est passé
exactement entre ce que le conducteur a
fait ou n'a pas fait et si les organes
ont répondu oh non pas répondu dès le 20
juillet le conseil d'administration de
la sncf avait adopté une série de
nouvelles mesures de sécurité par
exemple vérification systématique après
toute intervention sur les freins et les
circuits de commande
il a aussi été décidé de renforcer la
formation professionnelle relative aux
techniques de freinage
enfin il a été prévu d'installer des
liaisons téléphoniques entre le
conducteur et les voyageurs 2 milliards
de francs supplémentaires seront
consacrés cette année à la sécurité
malheureusement ces deux mesures ne
seront pas efficaces immédiatement moins
de huit minutes pour l'intervention
quelques heures seulement pour libérer
de la ferraille et évacué tous les
blessés de la gare de l'est
le plan rouge prévu en cas d'accident
grave et d'attentes a parfaitement
fonctionné
120 pompiers aidés de policiers des
personnels du samu ont prouvé toute
l'efficacité d'un système mis en place
il y a dix ans rémy roche depuis 10 ans
qu'il existe le plan rouge a été
déclenché et 28 fois un sens gilg en
importance attentats catastrophes
ferroviaires sa mise en oeuvre est
synonyme de gravité et de lourd bilan
synonyme également d'efficacité et de
rapidité
hier
la gare de l'est le plan rouge a été
activé moins de 20 minutes après la
collision
après que les premières équipes de
secours des pompiers est averti leurs
états majors de la gravité des dégâts
etc ont aperçu que l'affairé est
sérieuse a déclenché le plan rouge
sérieux c'est quoi ça veut dire qu'il ya
présomption de plusieurs nombreuses
victimes revenait un civil ont dit
victime
gare de lyon 27 juin dernier tragique
précédant la dernière fois que le plan
rouge avaient été déclenchées comme à la
gare de l'est envoi d'un dispositif
lourd prévu à l'avance en matériels
véhicules et en hommes une assistance
minimum pouvant sans cesse être
renforcée et en liaison avec le samu qui
a déclenché son plan blanc
réorganisation stratégique de la zone du
sinistre en zone de secours
ici l'officier ramassage qui s'occupe du
dégagement des victimes
l'officier tri pour mettre les victimes
en des cdg blessés graves et
éventuellement des cd qu'on transporte
trois par là et ensuite ce fléau la
fille évacuation hadjal noria des
véhicules dits vécu à sion fonds pied ou
samu le cheminement et en celui ci on
remonte par le 1er étage par l'escalier
on arrive donc à la sortie et vous avez
ici à droite le pc
j'organise l'ensemble des moyens sur le
site en trois heures et hier les 56
blessés de la gare de l'est était dégagé
et évacués vers des hôpitaux
il ya en france 32 mille adultes de 20
ans différents ils sont handicapés
mentaux antenne 2 a déjà largement
évoqué le cadre de ces jeunes de mieux
en mieux assumée par le famille mais que
la société n'accueille plus dans des
instituts médico éducatifs au delà de
cet âge de vingt ans alors quelques fois
ce sera la famille parfois des instituts
privés mais aussi l'hôpital
psychiatrique beaucoup comme le comédien
michel creton se bat pour que la
législation soit aménagée l'accueil est
tendue un exemple avalé près de nantes
valérie fournis ou philippe mon choisy
un dernier tour de clef sur l'enfance
sauf dérogation pour quatre jeunes
handicapés mentaux l'espoir de revenir
dans ce centre le 1er septembre
disparaît c'est la loi ils ont 20 ans
adultes
les familles sont désemparés comme
annick scellier seule avec trois enfants
bon je vais fermer
c'est très compliqué je verrai si c'est
un très gros problème ce même pas
comment j'ai fait rare écrit seul mais
tu voudrais retourner danser à tva était
content de ton stage c'était alors la
seat et ya pas de place et aucune course
elle a fait un stage hollande a donc une
place c'était une solution pour l'avenir
de christelle ces jeunes ont besoin plus
que tous les autres d'une surveillance
sans suivi médical et éducatif ans ils
vont perdre leurs acquis à régresser et
le ceat est tout à l'heure tu parlais du
seat et tu resté combien de temps on
stage à une semaine et ça t'a plu mais
ouais tu as fait quoi
sous la conduite lourd il faut savoir
que ces enfants qui n'auront pas de
centre à la rentrée ne sont pas en
vacances
donc à partir du moment où c'est qu'il
n'y a qu'une chose qui doit changer
c'est la loi la loi doit arrêter de dire
qu'à 20 ans des enfants rentrent dans
leur famille revient dans leur famille
et pour solutions souvent non que
d'aller dans un asile gérer les familles
refusent tout l'hôpital psychiatrique
leurs enfants ne sont pas fous en france
ils sont 32 milles dans ce cas les
familles condamne la loi qui limite la
vie sociale de leurs enfants à 20 ans il
ne faut pas au nom de grands principes
laisser vivre les handicapés
quand ils sont tout petits pour les
abandonner les rayer de la société à 20
ans il faut aller jusqu'au bout
moi je dis qu'à une lettre de ce genre
qu'on envoie aux familles on devrait
joindre une ordonnance qui permettrait
en même temps d'aller acheter l'ampoulé
de cyanure parce que il faut être
logique jusqu'au bout
malgré tout l'amour qu'une mère peut
porter à son fils seuls des
professionnels peuvent aider ces jeunes
différents à vivre presque comme les
autres l'étranger le roi hussein de
jordanie affirme ce soir que les
palestiniens de cisjordanie garderont
leur passeport jordanien jusqu'à
création d'un état palestinien
le souverain hachémite qui parlait donc
devant la télévision jordanienne
confirme également que son pays ne
fermera pas les deux ponts qui relient
les deux rives du jourdain jordanie et
cisjordanie une façon pour le roi de
rassurer les palestiniens des
territoires occupés
déboussolés par la rupture décidé à
amman entre jordanie et si jordan
l'afghanistan les troupes soviétiques
accélèrent leur retrait selon des
sources occidentales d'ici au 15 ou
cinquante mille soldats soviétiques
pourrait avoir quitté le pays
pourtant l'armée rouge à renforcer la
défense de kaboul
allez jean momentanément la pression
exercée à coups de roquettes sur la
capitale afghane
la situation il ya été suffisamment
difficile pour que plusieurs diplomates
occidentaux l'évacuent une provocation
selon les autorités afghanes
claude crespo les rues de kaboul
filmé par la télévision allemande on se
croirait une fin de semaine paisible à
l'entrée d'une ville occidentale et dans
le ciel afghan au dessus de l'aéroport
de kaboul
les hélicoptères de surveillance dans un
étrange ballet avec les avions de ligne
collier de fleurs autour du cou fanion
sourire des politesses images de la
télévision soviétique cette fois qui
fuit mais hier le retrait des troupes de
l'armée rouge
des images qui sembleraient confirmer un
retour à l'accalmie dans les tirs de
roquettes sur kaboul la capitale afghane
et pourtant depuis quelques semaines
l'objet de bombardements intensifs par
les moudjahidine peut-être que cette
accalmie n'est pas sans relation avec
les exceptionnels mesure de sécurité
provoquée par la visite edouard
chevardnadzé le trajet emprunté par le
ministre soviétique des affaires
étrangères que ce soit pour rencontrer
le président nagib ou là ou encore comme
sur ces images pour visiter une usine a
été l'objet de toutes les attentions des
troupes soviétiques gagnent la même
télévision soviétique s'attarde aussi
sur cette prise roquettes
ici le seul sol et des mille ans un
engin de fabrication franco allemande
que les moudjahidine utilisent pour
pilonner kaboul depuis près d'un mois
ces images datent d'hier et dans huit
jours
théoriquement la moitié du contingent
soviétique doit avoir fait comme ses
soldats quitter l'afghanistan
birmanie une nouvelle manifestation
d'étudiants dans les rues de rangoon la
police tire et tue cinq manifestants en
corée du sud bataille rangée entre
policiers anti émeutes et étudiants qui
veulent rencontrer leur homologue
nord-coréen à la veille des jeux
olympiques
une première dans le droit international
dissident soviétique le nationaliste
arménien par hui railleries qui entame
une procédure judiciaire pour obtenir le
droit de rentrer chez lui et de
retrouver sa nationalité
jacques merlino expulsé du res s est
déchu de sa citoyenneté soviétique par
ouïr eric ya en france depuis une
semaine va tenter une grande première
avec l'aide d'un avocat français il a
tout simplement l'intention de se
présenter devant les tribunaux
soviétique afin de faire annuler pour
illégalité
le décret prononçant son expulsion par
weir eric yankee souhaitait d'abord
s'installer aux etats-unis a changé
d'avis dès demain matin il se rendra au
consulat durée cesse et déposant une
demande de visa
cette démarche exceptionnelle pour un
dissident soviétique sera un test pour
juger de l'évolution de la justice en
urss
nous avons deux types de recours a
déposé le premier en réintégration de la
citoyenneté soviétique devant le
présidium du soviet suprême
deuxième possibilité si effectivement
fait première requête n'aboutit pas
c'est d'engager une requête devant la
juridiction de moscou en annulation des
actes illicites des fonctionnaires
c'est-à-dire le présidium du soviet
suprême et à cette occasion la
participation physique de par jour à
héritier est possible il est évident que
nous demanderons l'application de ce
droit tout en même temps que le
fonctionnaire qui a pris cet acte
illicite doit être présent et nous le
solliciteront bien évidemment à voir se
vider inconnus ont saccagé le domicile
de bernard margueritte un correspondant
de presse français mon confrère
travaille pour
pain et l'a5 l'un des membres de sa
famille a été grièvement blessé au
chapitre économie de ce journal un coup
d'oeil sur le tourisme en corse vous
savez que cette année sur le continent
pour ce début de saison
exception faite des restaurateurs les
chiffres d'affaires de ceux qui
travaillent pour les touristes sont à
peu près similaires à ceux de l'an
dernier
en corse le tourisme pourrait encore se
développer mais la capacité hôtelière
fait défaut et des attentats ternissent
parfois l'image en 87
la corse a accueilli 1 million 200 mille
touristes et deux milliards et demi de
francs
ils ont été dépensés le tourisme y
emploie un cinquième de la population
active
jérôme camille françois granier le
public étranger italiens et allemands
s'intéressent de plus en plus à la corse
mais les commerçants apparemment ils
trouvent pas leur compte
la saison touristique a été très
mauvaise jusqu'à maintenant et
maintenant il ya un tir rebelle
il ya un petit truc de tourisme
l'arrivée les charters a bousculé le
paysage aérien entre la corse et le
continent
les vols charters ont cassé les prix 590
francs basse saison et 850 francs saison
d' et le public a choisi
nous avons fait voyager l'année dernière
cent mille personnes
l'objectif que nous atteindrons pour
1988 et 260 ni voyageurs avec
aéromaritime qui assure pour nouvelles
frontières
les liaisons entre la corse et le
continent corsair est une compagnie
indépendante à capitaux corse qui attend
qu'une nouvelle réglementation casse le
monopole des deux compagnies nationales
actuellement nous avons des problèmes
avec l'administration qui nous limite
dans leur passion dans le cas de la
directive qu'elle est paralysé le ciel
français
les cadres et la possibilité aux
charters de se développer le demande en
direct des reptiles soit soient
supprimés soit des ans vraiment
améliorée de patrons puissent le faire
il apporte toute l'année à raison d'un
vol par jour
on sait bien sûr bastia curage active on
peut choisir aussi une mini croisière de
180 km entre le continent et la corse
longtemps la sncm a été préservé par la
concurrence
aujourd'hui les charters de la mer se
sont attaqués au coût de corse il ya
depuis un an un an et demi tassement des
acheteurs
je crois que il faut il faudra plus
raisonnée tellement en termes de saison
mais raisonner en année globale et tout
au moins nous c'est notre politique
c'est d'offrir des week-ends séjour en
contre séminaire international qui
peuvent amener sur la corse
harnes année pleine du monde le tourisme
a connu une période faste jusqu'en 1981
cette année lagence pour le tourisme
corse fait des efforts pour attirer la
clientèle du continent nous connaissons
une croissance régulière de la
fréquentation touristique dans l'île
mais avec une modification en profondeur
de la structure de cette fréquentation
puisque la clientèle nationale la
clientèle française se stabilise alors
que la clientèle étrangère est en
progression très fort la corse avec ses
1000 km de côtes ces températures d'été
qui varie entre 22 et 25 degrés est un
lieu idéal de vacances mais les
insulaires quelquefois gouttes les
touristes une nouvelle collision évité
de justesse dans le ciel près de l'ombre
de boeing deux compagnies britanniques
se sont croisés à 1200 mètres de
distance alors que les normes de
sécurité imposent 5000 mètres c'est le
quinzième incident de ce type
enregistrée par la direction de
l'aviation civile britannique depuis le
début du mois de mai plait-il je vous en
prie faites très peu pour moi merci pas
de fruits bonjour madame madame et
monsieur le comte
ces formules sont elle correcte
correspondent tel au savoir-vivre en
tout cas cet art qui est tout sauf une
et ça prend c'est vrai que parfois le
diplôme ne suffit pas et que le port de
la fourchette ou l'ongle manucure et
feront la différence pour l'embauché
d'un cadre de haut niveau de savoir
vivre ça prend il ce pays il est à la
mode
30 ghz lui ont été consacrés en 1987
jeanne lagier et claude barny
bonsoir igor igor n'est pas laissée en
simple visite dans un salon bourgeois
il apprend l'art du baise main à
l'institut du savoir vivre
quand vous vous penchez pour baiser la
main
vous ne devez pas toucher la main alors
nous allons recommencer à les y voilà
et bien c'est parfait parce que c'est
dans ce salon du 16e arrondissement à
paris que des jeunes et des moins jeunes
viennent s'initier à l'art des usages et
des bonnes manières
il leur en coûte la somme de 30 mille
francs pour 13 heures de cours
c'est très joli très élégant
j'évolue dans deux milieux qui sont
complètement différents milieux sportifs
et le milieu de la mode et je suis
confronté à aller dans certains dîners
ou jeu il est vrai je me trouve un peu
un peu surpris parce que j'ai quatre
coureurs de chaque côté et que je sais
pas à quel point
merci monsieur vous ne remercie pas on
vous sert le service de tarbes doivent
passer dans le plus grand silence et ne
doit pas couper la conversation donc
vous ne remettez pas poster ça se passe
tout seul et c'est que voilà on va dont
jean-pierre vous n'abordez pas dans
votre fruit
vous allez vous donner la peine de les
pêcher en le maintenant bien ce à dire
que vous piquez la fourchette dans votre
fruit et ensuite vous le couper en deux
le fruit de ne doit pas quitter votre
assiette de cette manière
j'ai lu que dans le court il ya des
expressions qui déclasse et j'aimerais
beaucoup savoir ce que c'est exactement
quelles sont les expressions qui
déclasse et vient igor il y en a un
grand nombre et c'est très important de
les connaître parce qu'effectivement
avec un seul mot prononcé de cbre là
vous vous déplacez vous pouvez être mal
jugé le fait de dire au revoir aux
plaisirs ou de dire bonjour messieurs
dames sens est très fâché évidemment ce
sont des choses qu'il ne faut absolument
pas dire si vous êtes content d'avoir vu
les gens lorsque voulait quitter ou leur
dit j'ai été ravi de vous connaître
mais on y vend chanter c'est un mot qui
déclasse
parmi tant d'autres comme vous dites
fait partie de l'élite à vos stagiaires
comment réagit style eh bien ils ont
d'entrée en juillet sont ravis à cette
idée ils viennent pour évoluer dans des
milieux auxquels ils souhaitent accéder
et faire partie de l'élite c'est une
idée qui n'est en chambre jamais le chic
et le bcbg n'ont été aussi couru jamais
il n'y a eu autant de guides du savoir
vivre
mais il serait détestable qu'il ne soit
qu'une suite d' usage formel le vrai
savoir-vivre reste d'abord celui du
coeur au revoir aux plaisirs bonjour
monsieur dame j'ai tout dit façon pour
votre serviteur de jouer de l'art du
déclassement l'information suivante
trouverait sans doute sa place dans une
rubrique diplomatique sous le terme
générique guerre propre ou propagande le
premier film de la série rambo sera en
effet diffusée prochainement union
soviétique surprise quand on connaît
lentilles soviétisme immédiate de ce
héros très musculeux du vietnam
delphine de la scène visions étranges
venus d'ailleurs rambo a roulé des
mécaniques sur les écrans moscovite
surprenant il y à peine quelques
semaines
sylvester stallone alias trop qui
étaient arrêtés à la frontière de
l'allemagne de l'est motif trop
vindicative et résolument anti
communiste dans ses oeuvres bien sûr
mais l'urss fait tout de même pomme de
tolérance et de bonne volonté après les
pop stars occidentales et le coca cola
le kremlin a adopté avec enthousiasme le
non moins musclée car ce n'est guère ce
premier tournage américain sur la place
rouge n'a pas fini d'étonner ceux qui se
remettent à peine des accords de
désarmement entre les deux super grand
fini donc le temps où tous ceux qui
venaient de l'ouest n'était que
propagande et désinformation alors glace
nost sur toute la ligne
pas tout à fait tout de même
le gombo dont il est question pour les
grosses d'écran soviétique est le seul
film de cette série où stallone
n'utilisent pas ces dons et mutent à
rendre fou les dirigeants communiquent
encore blague
le titre de ce film vante les mérites
d'un vétéran du vietnam montrée du doigt
par la société qu'il a voulu défendre
mais rodolphe ganis temps eux sont
décorés
ce qu'il fallait démontrer c'est senna
le brésilien qui remporte le grand prix
de hongrie de formule 1 et c'est alain
prost revenus de la septième place qui
est juste derrière à six grands prix de
la fin du championnat du monde les deux
hommes sont désormais premiers ex-aequo
avec 66 points
mécénat compte deux victoires de plus
qu'alain prost francis marotte
l' avantage d'ayrton senna sur alain
prost aujourd'hui sa place sur la grille
de départ le brésilien en première ligne
place huit concurrents entre lui et
prost
dès le feu vert seul nigel mansell tire
la route sénat mais pour peu de temps
le britannique qui chasse perd sa place
résultat tête à queue spectaculaire il
va repartir
mansell juste devant juste devant alain
prost
le français doit attendre trois quarts
d'heure pour passer mansell dans la
ligne droite les désormais la route est
libre ou rouler verbund scène et celle
un premier problème à résoudre pour
prost passé woodsen le belge toujours
aussi fair play ne ferme pas la porte
alain prost deuxième
et bientôt alain prost 1er mai pour peu
de temps ils passent sénat au bout de la
ligne droite dans le virage mais pour
vraiment très peu de temps le brésilien
lui refait l'intérieur
alors alors explications au micro de
lionel chamoulaud
j'arrive un tout petit peu trop vite
dans un virage il manquait très très
très peu et comme j'étais obligé d'aller
un peu à l'extérieur j'ai pris comme
d'habitude sur ce genre de circuit
la gomme et les gravillons et j'ai
commencé à glisser super des adhérences
post ne retrouvera jamais une autre
occasion de passer le brésilien
au classement général les deux pilotes
sont désormais à égalité mais avantage
sénat 6 victoires à 4
dernière journée des championnats de
france de natation à dunkerque noter
trois nouveaux records renault boucher
au 50 m dos en 26 secondes et 83
centièmes franco iacono 1500 m aux
quinze 100 m en 15 21 et 45 centièmes et
cécile prunier 1 800 m libre en 8
minutes 39 secondes et 20 centièmes le
championnat du monde moto le grand prix
de grande bretagne christian sarron et
troisième en cinq centimètres cubes
derrière l'américain rennais en deux
cent cinquante centimètres cubes son
frère dominique dominique sarron termine
deuxième le tiercé c'était cet après
midi à deux villes combinaison gagnante
eu 15 16 14 et leur appartenance dans
l'ordre pour 5 francs 36 1116 francs 50
dans un ordre différent 4165 francs le
quarté + 15 16 14 2 pour 6 francs dans
l'ordre 552 1988 francs et 80 centimes
dans un endroit différent 21000 27
francs 60 centimes le plus trio 860 877
franc 81 fin de cette édition dans un
instant laurent cabrol pour la météo ça
se gâte par le sud
prochain rendez vous d'information le
journal par jacques pradines haut à 23
heures avec un dossier consacré ce soir
aux droits des malades dans les hôpitaux
je vous retrouve pour ma part samedi
prochain excellente soirée à tous
et